you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast fume hoods going behind
the scenes with the industry's latest
technology it's presented by Beth manka
Meijer the sales engineer for chemical
fume hoods at lab không có we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by lab con co serving the
scientific community since 1925 lab con
co manufacturers laboratory equipment
specializing in ventilation products
such as chemical fume hoods and
biological safety cabinets other product
lines include glassware washers and
freeze dryers lab con co has ISO 9001
certification one measure of the
company's commitment to quality and
consistency in design and manufacturing
lab con co equipment is manufactured in
Kansas City Missouri and Fort Scott
Kansas and marketed worldwide to
academic industrial life science
pharmaceutical environmental forensic
and clinical laboratories to learn more
about lab concho please visit
www.opm.gov/life and I'll be your
moderator for today's event this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation just click on the green
shoe and a button located in lower left
of the presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce Beth Minka Meyer Beth has
presented multiple times at the American
industrial hygiene conference and
exposition and at VidCon before joining
lab
in 2013 that was a business development
manager at Ruskin company where she
focused on the manufacturing of louvers
for the HVAC industry and architectural
products
she holds degrees from the University of
Kansas and University of Saint Mary Beth
is a construction documents technologist
certified by the construction
specifications Institute and a LEED
Green Associate please join me in
welcoming Beth Minka Mayer I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you Judy
hello everybody I want to thank you for
joining my webinar today on fume hoods
my name is Bethany Mayer from lab con co
and if you have any questions while I'm
doing this webinar please be sure to
send those in so I can answer them so
without further ado let's get started
here is our agenda for this webinar
first we are going to review some basic
laboratory ventilation and then we're
going to talk about where few had
started and how the designs made their
way to what they are today then we're
going to talk specifically about high
performance fume hoods their definition
and what makes them different and we're
even going to compare two different type
reformists fume hoods against each other
to show that not every high-performance
fume hood is made equal then I have an
example showing how large of a return on
investment can occur just for switching
to a high-performance fume hood and then
we're going to switch gears and discuss
Dethlefs hoods and the different types
that are offered in today's market and
finally we will compare ducted fume
hoods to ductless fume hoods to see what
might might make sense for your lab if
you're in the market here are the items
that we're going to discuss as far as
basic laboratory ventilation just to
make sure everyone understands generally
how a few hood works so you can
differentiate it from other enclosures
and maybe even understand your lab a
little bit better so you may not know it
but the room that you're in has been
engineered to have a certain amount of
air
enter the room and a certain amount of
air leave the room this is true if
you're at home in a lab or at a shopping
mall the air entering the room is called
the supply air and the air exiting the
room is called the exhaust air it must
be balanced to maintain even pressure in
the room rooms can be slightly negative
or slightly positive for different
reasons however if one is off
significantly you will be able to tell
for example let's say it's summertime
and you turn your fume hood blower on
and it suddenly becomes very warm in the
room
this means the room is too negative it's
warm because all of the air-conditioned
air is being exhausted from the lab this
means there is not enough make up air
being supplied to the room so like most
things it's about finding balance so
before I get in all of the fume hood
talk I want to make sure we all know
that when more air is exhausted from the
room than supplied to it it's negatively
pressured and conversely when more air
is supplied to the room than exhausted
it's positively pressured these basic
rules give you the building blocks for
what we need to know for the rest of the
presentation
now we're getting in the fume hood
specific ventilation and how air moves
through a fume hood the room air is
going to be pulled through the hood via
the blower and exhaust it outside we
measure the air that is exhausted in a
few different ways first there is the
volumetric flow of air basically we're
going to take an amount of air and pull
it through the fume hood opening and
vent it outside the volumetric flow is
typically measured in cubic feet per
minute or CFM for short you'll hear CFM
a lot in this presentation and whenever
you talk about HVAC or air movement it's
saying that we are taking a cubic foot
and filling it with air and seeing how
many of those move in a minute so this
is how we measure the exhaust
requirements of a fume hood and the make
up air requirement
for the room the other measurement we
look at is the speed of the air going
through the front of the fume hood we
call that the face velocity depending on
how much air or CFM you're putting
through that front opening that will
determine the face velocity I like to
compare this to water because it's
relatable and you can see water and
since air and water are both fluids they
are comparable so think of watering
flowers in the garden with a garden hose
and picture some flowers being just out
of reach of the water coming out of the
hose so what can you do to make the
water reach the back flowers you can put
your thumb over the end blocking off a
portion of the hose opening the water
sprays further because the speed of the
water increases it's not increasing the
amount of water it's just the same
amount of water going through a smaller
opening and also within that same
relationship if you increase the amount
of water with the same opening on the
hose the velocity will increase same
thing with the fume hood and more the
more air you put through the fume hood
the faster the air will go through the
sash which is the glass window on the
hood that travels up and down we can
measure the face velocity of a fume hood
or the speed of the air entering the
plane of the sash with certain types of
equipment the anemometer measures the
speed of the air entering the space in
feet per minute or SPM for short you'll
see most of today's fume hoods published
with an operating range of 60 to 100
feet per minute sometimes they cannot be
operated as low as 60 feet per minute
and we'll get into that later during the
high performance hood discussion but for
now just pay attention to manufacturers
publish data to see what range is
acceptable so now we know what the
important air measurements are on a fume
hood but there are different types of
mechanical systems we can put the hood
on so we're going to take a quick look
at those now the two mechanical system
designs we will talk about today are
constant air volume and variable air
volume we will also just
that's the application specific reasons
for going with a certain mechanical
system you may hear constant air volume
and variable air volume referred to as C
AV and Vav
respectively these refer to the
volumetric flow or the CFM that we just
discussed the constant volume system has
the same amount of air exhausting
through the hood regardless of your sash
position so going back to the garden
hose example the face velocity or the
speed of the air is going to increase as
you close the sash
since you're putting the same amount of
air through a smaller opening the hood
has bypass areas to assist so the air
doesn't go too fast however it's still
going through the path of least
resistance and will mostly enter through
the sash opening unless the sash is
completely closed these types of setups
are best for smaller labs being or
limited use or specialty application
hoods wear hoods need to be on a
dedicated blower the other type of
mechanical system that I'll be
discussing a little bit more in depth is
the variable air volume system or Vav
which means that the amount of air
varies depending on the sash position
the reason for these systems is to save
energy and it's to save energy while the
hood is not in use many hoods are used
all day every day around the world and
since fume hoods are such heavy energy
users a lot of owners want to minimize
the amount of air they exhaust to
ultimately save on their buildings
energy costs this type of system is set
up with supply and exhaust control so
that you get maximum energy savings out
of the whole system by varying the
volumetric flow based upon the sash
position and it uses a valve or a damper
in the duct these systems are best for
large labs like general chemistry labs
where the fume hoods are running all the
time these systems usually feature a lot
of automation there are sensors that can
be placed on a fume hood so that when it
doesn't sense
in front of the hood the sash will close
and then automatically lower the
volumetric flow and result in savings
when the hood isn't in use so these will
have a larger upstart cost but when
they're used appropriately they will
save significant money in the long run
both of these systems can be used to
help with air changes in the laboratory
this is also a good time to add that
regardless of the mechanical system or
fume hood type the hood will only be
effective if the lab is well balanced
and the hood is placed away from cross
straps this image is showing that if
there is a hood place in front of a
supply air register you'll want to block
off the section that faces the fume hood
to eliminate the strong cross draft
coming from that location the bottom
line here is that the less cross traps
you have the better the hood will
perform since the air entering the hood
won't have to combat other air vectors
that are in front of the hood so here
shows a typical setup for abducted fume
hood then we have straight ductwork
that's coming off the top of the hood
into a 90 degree elbow to go into and
then some other straight document it
goes into the inlet of the blower and it
terminates in a vertical up direction
and it's very important that it
terminates this way in order to meet the
ANSI v 9.5 standard so if there are any
goose necks or caps on the end those
need to be replaced with a zero pressure
weather cap or some other type of stack
that allows the air to flow vertically
without taking whether in the blower is
what makes the fume hood work it is what
is pulling the air away from the user
and directing it outside the hood just
makes the air enter as efficiently as
possible so if you're finding something
wrong with the flow troubleshooting can
mean looking at the entire duct run
blowers also must be sized for their
duct runs to overcome the resistance of
traveling through all of the duct in
order to do that we look at how much air
we are putting through the specific duct
run design so we look at things like the
duct diameter and the
like the straight length and the number
of elbows to see how much resistance is
in that system which is the static
pressure the remote blower configuration
is the most typical for all few hood
setups the borer is mounted remotely
usually on a rooftop outside and it
keeps all the ductwork under negative
pressure this means if there's a leak in
your ductwork it will just keep sucking
air in through the leak so it is a
fail-safe for the best blower efficient
shape efficient efficiency keeps some
straight duct lengths in between
transitions it is not a good idea to put
an elbow right on top of a fume hood
duct collar the reason being it will
pull air faster on one side of the fume
hood and you'll lose blower efficiency
and you'll need to size up on your
blower in order to pull the right CFM so
a lot of times you will need to
challenge your blower with a damper I
compare this to making a smoothie so
when you have a lot of ice in your
blender and then some of the ice doesn't
get doesn't quite fall down to the
blades then you notice the blades then
very fast and you can sometimes even
smell the motor burning up it's the same
concept with a fume hood blower these
motors like to have some resistance in
order to function in their prime fan
curve the damper helps to add resistance
to that duct drum the built-in blower
configuration is a simpler configuration
where the blower is installed right on
top of the fume hood and it's actually
pushing the air out these are good for
short duct runs that don't travel
through occupied spaces so something
like a mobile lab would be appropriate
for that the reason being if a leak
develops in the built-in blower
configuration the duct is underneath I'm
sorry the duct is under positive
pressure and they will push the
contaminated air out of the leak
location so if your dust is traveling
through an office building with multiple
floors and you are working with a
hazardous chemical then it will leak
into the other occupants space if a leak
developed in that
drum and so there they're going to be
breathing in whatever you're working
with so it's always better to go with
the remote blower and only if you cannot
make that work should you go with the
built-in blower ASHRAE 110 is the
American test standard developed for
fume hoods and it's a three-part test
that consists of measuring the face
velocity profile the smoke visualization
test and the tracer gas test with a
mannequin placed in front of the fume
hood to mimic a person and their
breathing zone it can be rated as as
manufactured meaning the hood was tested
off the assembly line as installed
meaning the hood is newly installed in
the lab or as used meaning the hood is
installed and the operational equipment
and implements are in the hood as it's
being tested so this is really just the
test standard and it doesn't say
anything about passing or failing and
this test can be done on any fume hood
type and I'm going to reference this
test later when we talk about high
performance fume hoods so in the next
three slides I'm going to show three
different fume hood types to further
show how they're different from each
other
so the first is the typical bypass hood
this is a typical hood that goes on a
constant air volume system and this hood
has bypass areas for the air to enter
with as you said shut the sash so hence
the name bypass ax so this image is
showing the sash open on the left and
the sash closed on the right to show
where the room air enters the fume hood
when the sash is open and shut and you
can see that it's entering through the
upper bypass behind the sash and through
the airfoil opening at the work surface
when the fascist shut and over the years
hoods have evolved really due to energy
costs so in the 1970s the auxilary air
hood was invented the concept is that
instead of just exhausting all the air
from the room
since you're paying so much money to
condition that air why not just force
air directly from the outside into the
hood and only require about half the air
from the air conditioner so on paper
this is a fantastic idea some saves half
your energy but in practice however with
the fash open when the user is standing
right in front of the fume hood
it actually pours all the outside air
directly on the user creating a
potentially uncomfortable working
condition like thinking of in the middle
of summer down in Texas
it also creates a cross draft of air
right in front of the sash with the sash
closed it does its job and pours the
outside air directly in the fume hood
interior these types of hoods are
actually not recommended anymore and
they're not even produced by many
manufacturers in fact prudent practices
in the lot in the laboratory handling
and management of chemical hazards
states auxilary air hoods should not be
purchased for new installations and
existing auxilary air hoods should be
replaced or modified to eliminate the
supply air feature of the hood so in
today's hood world there really
shouldn't be a need for these since most
new hoods have high performance
technology that can use less air without
the need for the auxilary air source
then in the 1980s the Vav concept came
into play the left image shows the fash
fully open and the right image shows the
sash fully closed
Vav hoods can change the exhaust volume
using different methods one being a
damper or valve in the exhaust duct that
opens and closes based on a sash
position which that is shown in this
image in the ductwork above the fume
hood or they may have a blower that
changes speeds to mean air volume
demands Vav hoods will require a
restricted bypass which sometimes is
referred to as a bypass block and that
is there to create a passive resistance
and ensure adequate space velocity at
any sash position
so then came the 2000s were the first
high-performance fume hoods were
developed you may also hear these types
of hoods called low flow or high
efficiency or low velocity they are all
acceptable for use on a constant air
volume or a Vav system and they can be
operated down the 60 feet per minute
face velocity in a laboratory setting
there are only so many hoods that can
call themselves a high performance team
hood so I'll explain how they are tested
and how they earn that title going back
to the ASHRAE one time containment test
the test can be performed at different
phase velocities and sometimes they are
challenged at a very low level so the
lowest operating airflow that's allowed
in a laboratory is 60 feet per minute as
stated in standards like OSHA FIFA and
the industrial ventilation manual of
recommended practices FIFA is the
scientific equipment and furniture
Association and they're an organization
made of industry manufacturers and
representatives who created the
definition of a high performance fume
hood the definition states that the hood
must pass the ASHRAE 110 containment
test operating at 60 feet per minute
base velocity with the sash fully open
which is defined as a minimum of 25
inches open and on average less than
0.05 parts per million of the tracer gas
can be detected in an as manufactured
test so that means it was tested by the
manufacturer right off the assembly line
in their test lab if this test is done
in the field as an as installed or as
used test it actually allows an average
of 0.1 part per million of the tracer
gas to be detected with the same fully
opened sash position and 60 feet per
minute face velocity setup so in the
test lab it allows 0.05 parts per
million and if it's as installed or as
used it allows 0.1 parts per million so
keep in mind manufacturers that say
there
our high performance should have the
test reports to back that information up
FIFA itself states the following note
low-flow hoods which achieve a reduction
in volumetric flow by restricting the
sash opening area do not qualify as low
velocity or high performance fume hoods
unless they also meet the repor formance
requirements listed above through the
maximum sash opening the maximum sash
opening shall be considered a vertical
sash opening not less than 25 inches
high off the human work surface that was
a quote from FIFA that basically states
that you may see a fume hood touted to
operate at 60 feet permanent phase
velocity but that is not a high
performance hood unless it was tested
with the fash fully open aim achieved an
average of 0.05 parts per million or
less in an Ag manufactured condition so
if the published data only showed 60
feet per minute but the sash opening is
18 inches that is not a high performance
fume hood because the challenge comes
from having the sash raised above the
breeding zone this doesn't mean the fume
hood can't operate in the field with the
fash at 18 inches but in order to call
itself a high performance fume hood it
needs to pass the test with the fash
fully open so now that we know what a
high-performance fume hood is let's look
at some reasons why it's better than a
traditional fume hood here is a
computational fluid dynamics image of
the lab on Co extreme fume hood during
an azure a110 test which lab concho
tests down the 40 feet per minute face
velocity to give the user a large margin
of error when they operate at 60 feet
per minute what you're seeing is the
sulfur hexafluoride tracer gas plume and
how it is taken directly back into the
vessel this is exactly what you want to
see in this scenario and we're going to
go over the technology that helps it
move this way here we have another CFD
image this time showing a traditional
design in this image the red lines
represent where the
is traveling and you can see the large
roll at the top that is air vortexing
and rolling behind the sash it's okay if
it stays there but there's a risk of
that contaminated air coming down into
the breathing zone then on the
high-performance side we have air
entering the hood and traveling almost
straight back to the baffle to be taken
away out of the breeding zone this is
what we want to see to practically
eliminate that role that happens at the
top of the hood this way there's no risk
of that contaminated air coming back and
entering the breathing zone now we're
going to talk about the patented design
features that make lab konk Oh high
performance hoods work this is to show
you why a regular hood cannot perform
like a high performance hood these
engineered features are the reason the
air moves more efficiently through these
hoods the Clean Sweep technology refers
to the sash handle and fast track
opening where air can enter in a smooth
fashion and bring to dominance back when
our hoods were redesigned in 2012 the
sash handle was a very important place
for improvement over what was currently
being offered since the sash handle is
the closest feature near your breathing
zone so since we have this rounded and
slotted sash handle it allows the air to
move aerodynamically so that room air
enters and corrects turbulence at that
area here's an image showing the fluid
dynamics of that sash handle so the air
glides into the hood in the desirable
pattern very smooth taking contaminates
contaminants away from the breathing
zone here is a CFD image showing another
extremely important area of the fume
hood the airfoil the reason this area is
so important is that vapors can actually
linger on the work surface and we want
to make sure those are taken away so the
airfoil
the component that directs the air
across the work surface to the baffle
laughs Kanto does have a unique airfoil
it's called an eco foil and it was
developed after testing over 50
prototype prototype models the eco foil
is one of the components that makes
these hoods high performance because it
corrects turbulence so that when the air
enters the hood it's entering smoothly
with more of the same direction and if
you have a more air moving in the same
direction it will be more effective at
taking contaminants in the desired
direction which in this case is away
from the user and straight to the baffle
the baffle shown here is what offered on
our Xtreme fume hood it's the OP these
own system and it's referring to the
different slot hole sizes so it actually
creates a uniform face velocity profile
which if you remember in the ASHRAE 110
test that's part of that test so you
want the air to be entering the hood at
the same speed across the face so you
want it to be entering at the same speed
in the middle and you want it to be
entering at the same speed at the sides
and so this is actually what directs the
air to do that here is a CFD image of
the baffle on the extreme fume hood and
you can see it has a double baffle
system
which is a feature that makes more of a
suction at the baffle so if they first
get close the air is moving so fast that
it will get taken away and not linger in
the fume hood so now I'm going to go
over the numbers with you I was tasked
with persuading a design professional to
specify lab không có hood over a
competitor who also offers a high
performance hood so we're seeing the
high performance head to head so this is
going to show you that not all high
performance hoods are alike and you'll
see how much money was saved by going
with the lab Tonko hood so this customer
required a a set point of a hundred feet
per minute based velocity at a fashion
18
inches above the work surface and for
that philosophy equipment for that
velocity requirement the lab comm Co
hood only requires 720 CFM but the
competitors hood requires 830 CFM so to
be clear
both of these hoods will operate at a
hundred feet per minute face velocity
with the sash open 18 inches above the
work surface but because of design
differences the lab console hood
requires less air a lot of people
misunderstand this concept so I'm
actually going to say it in a different
way if your facility requires 100 feet
per minute when the sash is 18 inches
open you must look at the fume hood
manufacturers published CFM for
reference a lot of engineers will just
calculate this based on the sash opening
and you simply cannot do that on a fume
hood since there are too many variables
when you're sizing blowers and and all
of that so what you're going to end up
with if you do do that is a room that
isn't properly balanced or significant
over sizing of a system which equals
wasted money so in this example I looked
at webcam Co CFM requirements and our
competitors which we'll just call hood B
and on this particular project there
were 45 hoods so I took the difference
between hood B's CFM and last Campos CFM
and multiplied it by 45 hoods and the
difference is 4950 CFM so it almost
becomes four five thousand cubic feet
per minute so picture five thousand
cubes that are one foot by one foot by
one foot if an engineer were to size the
system based upon a calculation instead
of the manufacturers published data the
system could be off by five thousand CFM
so it's imperative to size based on the
manufacturers published data we're going
to keep this number in our back pocket
to calculate annual energy cost but
first we're going to look at the startup
cost since those impact your budget
immediately
so this was a new building so they were
looking at sizing their supply air
requirements so we're going to look at
how much money they saved in make up air
costs by going with the lab condo hood
we have the following constants here
with laboratories you cannot recirculate
air coming out of a fume hood exhaust so
it is all called first pass air so it
has to enter the lab and be exhausted
not recirculate like a residential or
office building so this brings the
estimate and labs to about 200 CFM per
ton of a/c and this is a conservative
estimate because I've actually seen this
number go down to about 130 CFM per ton
so just for reference in your home if
someone sizing a new air conditioning
unit they can use about 400 CFM per ton
so labs obviously have more of a demand
we can estimate that this unit will be
about 1,800 dollars per ton and so we'll
take the difference from the previous
slide which was four thousand nine
hundred and fifty and we'll divide it by
how many CFM per ton that was 200 and
then so we get the requirement to be
about 25 tons and then we're going to
take that times the $1,800 and we get
$45,000 that was saved even before a
hood is purchased so that number alone
will pay for five or six fume hoods and
I'm just showing you this to show if
you're looking at fume hood prices
sometimes the cheapest hood actually
shakes out to be more expensive because
it will require more air so it needs to
be looked at as a whole so now we're
actually going to calculate how much we
save on the annual basis just operating
a lab không có hood versus the
competitors hood a good conservative
estimate for energy cost is $7.00 per
CFM per year this would be higher on the
East Coast but it's a really good number
for the middle of the road so if we take
that original difference of the CFM
times seven dollars per CFM per year we
get thirty four thousand six hundred and
fifty so this is how much we would say
per year if the hoods operate 24/7 all
the time so let's say the hoods are on a
Vav system and they're only operating
half the year we're still saving
seventeen thousand three hundred
twenty-five dollars every year so that's
not too bad then if we multiply that
over the life of the hood so they ten
years we will get one hundred and
seventy three dollars into 173 eight
thousand two hundred fifty dollars and
then we're going to add the startup
costs in and we saved two hundred and
eighteen thousand two hundred fifty
dollars just by going with the lab panco
high-performance hood and this isn't
even mentioning that you're lowering
your carbon footprint by how much
because you're saving five thousand CFM
per year basically so it's you're using
less energy overall so this slide shows
some good estimates for how much savings
in percentage terms you can expect just
from going from a constant volume hood
to a high-performance hood and then a
Vav hood and then finally kind of
merging everything together and putting
your high performance hood on a Vav
system with a motion detector sash
system so it could equal over a 90%
reduction in your CFM which means saving
a lot of money and lowering your carbon
footprint again so it's a win-win so
that wraps up our abducted conversation
for the moment and we're going to switch
gears and talk about ductless hoods now
so just so everyone's on the same page
ductless enclosures are self-contained
workstations that use carbon filters to
protect the operator from harmful vapors
they obviously require no duct and the
contaminated air circulates through
carbon filtration and flows back into
the room and it's cleansed of the
chemical vapors so these are ideal for
your temporary or leased spaces or areas
where you wouldn't be able to duct out
like a basement or in the case
of this photo at the Denver Museum of
Nature and Science where the lab is
actually directly under the sinus or
ductwork wouldn't look too nice going
through that dinosaur would it so I will
go over the applications that are not
appropriate for this type of enclosure
and also discuss the definitions of the
three different types of ductless hoods
in the slides ahead the same
organization that created the definition
for a high-performance fume hood also
created the ductless hood definitions
that organization once again is FIFA the
scientific equipment and furniture
Association so the D h1 is defined as a
ductless hood equipped with a filtration
device designed to control non-toxic
chemicals
nuisance odors particulates so this
enclosure is just for nuisance papers or
non hazardous chemistry these are going
to typically have application specific
carbon filters to cover chemical
families like acid sulfur formaldehyde
or ammonia these enclosures also
typically don't come with a sensor so
changing the filter depends on motor
breakthrough unless you use some kind of
a secondary sensor at lab Camco we call
this enclosure a fume absorber or a
protector workstation the dh2 is defined
as a ductless hood capable of meeting
all dh1 requirements and equipped with a
filtration device design the filter
manufacturer approved toxic contaminants
up to filter breakthrough only but the
h2 ductless hood is not designed to
provide secondary containment beyond
primary filter breakthrough so it must
meet all the requirements of a dh1 and
also be able to filter hazardous
chemistry and have a sensor these
enclosures also have application
specific carbon filters to cover the
chemical families and the sensor is
located on top on the top of the filter
stack on this type of enclosure so once
the filter breakthrough has been sensed
the application should stop and the
filters need to be
change and at lab comm Co we call this
enclosure a paramount the dh3 is the
final definition it is a ductless hood
capable of meeting all the h2
requirements and equipped with a
filtration device designed the filter
manufacturer approved toxic contaminants
beyond primary filter breakthrough by
providing secondary backup protection
once the primary filter breakthrough
point has been detected a dh3 ductless
hood should be designed to provide a
period of time to continue and an
ongoing experiment with its secondary
backup filter system the secondary
filter must be of the same type of media
and efficacy as the primary filter so
these hoods typically have one universal
carbon type that can actually filter out
acids bases and solvents and at lab con
Co the dh3 products are called the
protector echo and protector arrow or
the echo and the arrow those hoods are
actually a marriage of products between
lab con co and a company called our lab
using their green fume hood technology
so we refer to this as a filtered fume
hood to differentiate it from other
ductless hoods because when we get phone
calls that just say I need a ductless
hood you can see that there's a really
large range to narrow it down from so
since the echo and the arrow can do so
much more than the B h1 and the P h2 and
even the minimum requirements of the dh3
it's an easy way to differentiate it
when you are talking in the world of
ductless and filtered fume hoods this
slide elaborates on the way the filtered
fume hood is differentiated from the pH
one and the d h2 so the bh3 the filtered
fume hood they are the closest thing to
a general chemistry fume hood without
being ducted out so since they have that
comprehensive filter they can filter the
wide range of chemicals and since they
have a secondary filter that's the same
type as the primary filter they can
detect
while still maintaining safety so once
you have filter break through a filter
change still needs to happen however the
application doesn't need to stop
immediately since it's still being
filter that has a brand new filter
that's on top of the sensor so these
hoods can also communicate their status
via a software package accessory and
they can integrate an application
successfully these hoods also have
places where services can be piped into
the corner post and the filters are
larger so the maintenance can actually
be spread out further the Box on the
front that you see in the photo has a
built-in computer that tracks the user
stash position filter life alarm history
and it's able to be seen by let's say
you're in a university lab the
instructor is able to go back and look
at all of that data so for any
manufacturer of carbon filtered
enclosures to protect you in the
manufacturer the first step will always
be to fill out a chemical assessment
form so this ensures your application is
appropriate for the fume hood and it
also is going to help the manufacturer
determine what hood type to choose out
of the three different definitions also
with this information we can estimate
the filter life for your application so
if you're interested in a carbon
filtered enclosure be prepared to fill
one of these out it will ask for things
like the type of handling your chemical
names type of container whether it's
open or closed the dilution percentage
the temperature handling frequency
quantity and duration of use so
basically the more detail you put into
the chemical assessment form the more
accurate we can be on the expected
filter life so some people call in and
ask me which is better ducted or
ductless so I always have to tell them
in the fume hood world there is nothing
that is black and white and it's not as
easy as that unfortunately so it's
really about weighing the pros and
the one large consideration often gets
overlooked is the maintenance part of
having a ductless hood so I always try
and be as transparent as possible to
show what's involved in owning one of
these hoods since most people that have
abducted hoods do not have to deal with
much maintenance except for you know
servicing the blower or Vav system every
once in a while so otherwise the ducted
hoods are mostly set it and forget it
the filters will need to be changed on a
ductless hood regardless of what type
you have in some centers will need to be
replaced depending on what type of hood
you have on a regular basis also user
trainings become even more important
because the user has to know what to do
in the event of alarm because on these
hoods there are usually more alarms than
just the low airflow that you would see
normally on a ducted hood so keeping all
personnel trained is key with the
ductless enclosures so here are some
photos of what happens behind the header
panels on different lab comm code
ductless fume hoods the one on the left
is the dh3 or filtered fume hood and the
one on the right is the d h2 the
Paramount so they both have stacked
components so you need to make sure you
have full access to the top of the fume
hood
if you're considering a ductless fume
hood also since the air comes back into
the room it's important to have an air
gap on top of the filters so the air can
recirculate back into the room so for
this reason ceiling enclosures or the
metal shrouds that go around ductwork
are strongly discouraged on these hoods
since a lot of times that air gets put
into the ceiling grid and you might
think you know why do you even need a
ceiling enclosure on a ductless hood
because there isn't any duct cover up
well some people just still really like
the appearance of it but in this
situation we're going to take the safety
in the fume hood effectiveness over
appearance so because going back to that
room pressurization conversation if
you're taking air from the room and
putting it into a different space
without having makeup air
you're going to create a negative
pressure and you're going to throw off
that balance in the room and it will
affect your fume hood containment so we
already discussed the maintenance
conversation because a typical ducted
hood has minimal maintenance after it's
installed the infrastructure and remote
lower may take some extra effort but
once there's that you won't need to
think about them for a while
so with a ductless hood the maintenance
schedule needs to be planned out because
it's up to the facility to make
arrangements for filter changes and
disposal as well as recommissioning the
hoods after the filter changes so with
the ducted hood the user can be a little
more lenient with the chemicals used you
don't have to worry about filling up
filters or not being able to use certain
chemicals at all and in most cases with
a ducted hood the worst that can happen
is your fume hood liner will corrode and
you'll have to replace it you wouldn't
have to worry about your filter having
break through and possibly stopping the
work before it's complete as long as
your blower is going on a ducted hood
the fume hood is pretty much going to
work also abducted hood can assist with
your minimum laboratory exhaust
requirements there are minimum air
changes for every space even office
spaces laboratories tend to have more
air changes so the fume hood can help
with that
the ductless hood cannot so the general
building exhausts would need to be sized
accordingly but on the other side of the
coin the ducted hoods require
infrastructure and you have to account
for the make-up air the ductwork
mounting blowers on your rooftop so you
add all those and they all add up costs
on a project and in some cases it might
be really difficult to route ductwork
and mount a blower so here are four
things to consider when looking to make
a decision on a ducted or a ductless
fume hood first check to see if the
application is even a good candidate so
you're going to fill out your chemical
assessment form and then you're going to
let the manufacturer analyze your
application so things that
fill up the filters quickly such as
forced evaporation would not be a good
fit and we'll go into some more detail
about some good and bad bits here in a
little bit the chemical assessment form
will also tell the manufacturer if the
chemicals you are using will be
effectively filtered basically we will
be able to look up the chemicals you're
using and see if they have a good
affinity to carbon and if they don't it
will not be a good fit and then you can
look at the cost of the filter
replacement to come up with your
expected maintenance cost and weigh the
pros and cons to see if that's the
direction you want to go in so here's
another quick reference pros and cons
list on the ductless fume hoods to
summarize what I've been talking about
so the great things are that they're
portable and flexible and they don't
impose a drain on your HVAC system since
they don't exhaust air out but they do
require maintenance and you do have to
be mindful of what applications can be
done in that hood and those applications
are the ones that have to be cleared
with the manufacturer so extra training
needs to be done to make sure the users
are aware of how to be how to use the
equipment and be mindful of what alarms
may happen so I'm just going to touch
really quickly on testing since the
ductless hoods are a little different
the sulfur hexafluoride tracer gas
that's used in a standard ASHRAE test
will actually go straight through the
carbon filters so in lab compost test
lab we hooked up a canopy to the hood to
capture the vapors and we actually
perform the standard ASHRAE 110 test we
also performed a modified ASHRAE test
that the one that can be done in the
field and it's basically putting some
isopropyl alcohol in a in a metal tray
in the fume hood and then using putting
the mannequin in front of the hood just
like normal and using a PID detector to
see to basically see if it detects any
of that IPA that's in the metal tray so
the setup is the same the mannequins in
front of the hood
tracer is just different and it's
allowed to evaporate in the hood so when
you're weighing the pros and the cons of
costs on a project going from ducted to
ductless for the ducted take into
account all of the infrastructure if it
doesn't that does not need to be
purchased as well as the annual energy
cost and for the ductless take into
account the filters and any sensors that
need to be purchased on the example from
before the actual annual energy cost for
the lab không có hood would be about one
hundred and thirteen thousand four
hundred dollars so that's how much if
the hoods were operating half the year
that's how much the hood would actually
cost to operate the Douglases would be
zero dollars compared to that but on
that same size job the start-up filter
costs would be about three hundred and
sixty thousand dollars since there were
45 hoods than they were six foot fume
hoods so there isn't always a clear-cut
answer of which way to go
and ultimately the choice is going to be
a factor of many different variables and
it actually might turn out that a
mixture of both ducted and ductless is
where you ultimately end up so to make
your decision even easier here are some
more applications where you would
absolutely want to go ducted so anytime
you have a specialty application such as
acid digestion with forced evaporation
or perchloric acid use those foods
require a washdown system and a
dedicated exhaust blower so you cannot
go with ductless also anytime you have a
classified hazardous location and the
hood needs to be explosion-proof or void
of spark potential those are one and the
same the fans are in the air stream in a
ductless hood and there are electronic
components that are not be p rated so
that would take the ductless hood out of
contention or if you just simply don't
want the maintenance burden so other
applications where you would want to go
with ducted
are your highly exothermic reactions so
something that might cause a lot of
smoke something like that or using
mercury insecticides or hydrogen cyanide
another important thing I will mention
is sometimes when I get calls where
people say you know oh I'm not working
with anything too terrible so it
shouldn't be a problem
because people try and get out of
filling out that chemical assessment
form but there are four chemicals that
are really not a good fit if you're
using it in any kind of volume so those
are acetone ethanol methanol and a/c to
my trial so once again those are acetone
ethanol methanol and a seed and I trial
they are chemicals that people typically
do not be as very harsh so if you use
any of those four chemicals on a regular
basis then it would not be a good fit
since the filter capacity is very low
for those chemicals so something like a
cleaning procedure involving acetone
would definitely want to go ducted so to
sum it all up ducted hoods can pretty
much take all applications you may just
need to modify the liner material or
mechanical system for a specific
application
ductless hood so dh1 and dh2 hoods use
chemical family specific activated
carbon filters and filtered fume hoods
or the dh3 hoods have one comprehensive
filter type to use on acid spaces and
solvents they also have the secondary
filter after the sensor to ensure safety
after break through and you will
absolutely want to go ducted with the
specialty hood applications or forced
evaporations and anything with the four
low molecular weight solvents I
mentioned before so everyone we have
reached the end and I hope you've
enjoyed this webinar I've certainly
enjoyed sharing my time with you today
if you have any questions at all please
feel free to send those in I just want
to say thanks again for spending your
valuable time with me today
I hope you're able to take some of this
new knowledge and apply it to your lab
and have a great rest of your day and
stick around if you'd like to listen to
some QA thanks so much
Thank You Beth for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A and if
you have a question you'd like to ask
Beth manka Meir please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is
what type of ductwork should I use with
my fume hood that's a good question
so a lot of times people people ask me
this question and basically you want to
make sure that your duct material is
going to meet any kind of local fire
codes and also be compatible with the
chemicals that you're working with so if
it meets those kind of those two
criteria then it would be a good fit
there isn't necessarily like a black and
white answer for what duct material to
to use if stainless steel a good
material to use for the fume hood liner
as a general rule yeah that's a good
question
so a lot of people call in and they ask
is they people think that stainless
steel is kind of this comprehensive
material that would be used in fume
hoods and the truth is people actually
then call in if they have chemicals that
they're using that aren't compatible so
any kind of mineral acids something that
would corrode the stainless steel that
would not be a good idea so the same
question kind of applies to the ductwork
question where if you're using something
like a mineral acid that would that
would corrode the stainless steel that
would not be a good idea and obviously
when you're getting into specialty
applications you'll have to look because
there are things like stainless steel
perchloric acid fume hoods if you were
using something other than perchloric
acid that would affect that stainless
steels and it would not be a good idea
so typically for general chemistry fume
hoods what you're going to see is
fiberglass wine because fiberglass has a
very wide range of chemical resistance
for example I mean all about conchos
fume hoods the general chemistry fume
hoods are lined in in some type of
fiberglass liner and we do see that with
our competitors as well that they they
offer a material called FRP
we that's what we have to for our Excel
and Xtreme so FRP is fiberglass
reinforced polyester so if you're
looking for general chemistry I would
recommend the fiberglass which hood
would you recommend for carcinogens so
that kind of depends because if it it
might not be a fume hood that you're
necessarily looking for it might be
something like a biosafety cabinet so I
would probably have to look at that
application a little bit better because
you have to think with a fume hood
you're just taking whatever is in the
hood and you're putting it outside so
with carcinogens it it depends on what
you're working with to be honest and if
you need some kind of a filter in that
system so typically I guess you would go
ducted or if you needed something
specific that where you would have to
have it filtered out I guess I would
just have to look at that on a
case-by-case basis if I'm using
flammable chemicals do I need an
explosion-proof fume hood so my blanket
answer to that is typically no so you're
just because you're using flammable
chemicals does not mean you need an
explosion-proof fume hood when we're
talking about explosion-proof fume hoods
we look at removing the source of a
spark in the on the actual fume hood and
it actually refers to the exterior more
than the interior because the interior
doesn't have any electrical components
so if you are putting the fume hood in a
room that has a high concentration of
flammable vapors or chemicals that is
when you need an explosion-proof fume
hood so if it is classified if it's
going into a room that's classified as a
hazardous location then that is when you
need an explosion-proof fume hood
there's a lot of misconception about
explosion-proof
so if you're just working with flammable
chemicals a standard fume hood
be fine because you're going to dilute
the interior of your fume hood with room
hair so typically it is just fine to go
with a standard fume hood well I would
like to once again thank Beth manka
Meyer for her presentation do you have
any final comments no I just want to
thank everyone for spending their time
with me today I really appreciate it and
I hope everyone learned something new
well thank you once again I would also
like to thank our sponsor lab không có
for making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CD button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from laborat and
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
when your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye